e
[Musique]
je
ce que tinqueux je considère bafouée
beaucoup de gens nous ont signifié ne
pas être venu voter parce qu'ils donnent
tout simplement entendu à la télévision
qu'il fallait limiter ses déplacements
et rester à domicile
[Musique]
bon
il
à
le gouvernement eut raison de maintenir
le spectacle oui je crois oui oui oui
parce que moi j'ai comme je vois comme
des virologues qui s'expriment qui
explique que cette humaines graves à
prendre en compte c'est la bnf
on dira aussi ça tue moi ça dure pas
plus de gens que la grille trop en
france
oui je pense qu'il faut les organiser
[Musique]
la journée de vote s'est achevé et elle
s'est bien déroulé pourtant samedi soir
les annonces de dernière minute du
gouvernement ont créé un grand trouble
et un sentiment d' incohérences la
fermeture la veille du scrutin de
l'ensemble des commerces non
indispensables fut un choix
incompréhensible pour nombre de nos
compatriotes
[Musique]